so this is zayan this is the second time
he's coming on winners wednesday but
this dude is absolutely killing on the
serviced accommodation rent to rent side
last time he came he was making four or
five thousand pound a month now he's
scaled up big time so let's see what
happens
yes yes come on through bro
what's happening man good to see ya
thanks so much for coming down thank you
so much for having me respect man
good to see you bro hey it's so good to
have you in my house we met on winners
wednesday maybe five six months ago and
you have
not only taken your service
accommodation business and really grown
it
but you've also managed to survive
through lockdown so i thought i've got
to get you back in you've you're killing
it
it's great to see you doing really well
so welcome back to winners wednesday
appreciate the invite mate house just
everyone knows it's absolutely insanely
beautiful so thanks for
very much for the invitation i
appreciate that you've got an
interesting energy as well because
you're like an absolute driven
make it happen person nothing can stop
you nothing will stop you
so when we if for anyone that's not
watched the first winners i'd recommend
go back and check it out
when we met last on camera you were
making about four or five thousand
pounds a month
and that was through your rent to rent
service accommodation business
you'd been to the crash course you've
done some training
you'd worked really hard and that's
where you're at
what's happened since then well for vote
for those people who have
watched it they could remember me saying
that oh by 2020 by next year i'll be
hitting the six figure mark which
thankfully and you know blessings to say
that we've hit that
with in just the service accommodation
and rent to rent it's a
grossing over six figures which is
absolutely amazing
and then going into deal sourcing as
well
extra revenue and it's things are just
going absolutely amazing man
even considering like lockdown and stuff
um
we managed to survive it what what what
is the difference between people that
have managed to succeed through lockdown
and people because there's been so many
people you know this that have been
giving their keys back to landlords
i mean we had some rentals we gave the
keys back and
most of them are doing okay most of our
students they're doing okay
many people have been here especially
people that didn't have the
systems the education the team you know
a lot of people that their
service combination businesses have just
absolutely struggled and suffered
what have you done to differentiate
yourself so there's a few different
things that we did and
a lot of people hopefully people will
learn from what i'm about to say here is
that
a lot of people who get into service
accommodation or rent to rent rental
essay
they come in thinking the only thing
that they need to do
is list on airbnb listonbooking.com on
all the other
otas that's what most people think that
you have to do
and get good reviews and all that other
kind of stuff which is fair enough
that's how exactly how i started
but then lockdown happened then what
happened airbnb
which is everyone's essays bread and
butter
locked off three months calendars locked
off cancelled everything
policies cancellation policies all gone
everyone was just effed basically so
what what could you do
everyone was just don't get me wrong
when that happened though i absolutely
you know pooed myself at the start
because i was thinking what can i do
yeah
what what's happening here so every i
think not just myself but everyone else
who was in the situation had a bit of a
mind
uh you know a mind freeze or whatever to
think okay what can we actually do here
so for those people who are actually
relying on airbnb and stuff i know
so many people who actually had to give
back their properties which is obviously
sucks but you know what can you do
but what we did was is actually thought
to ourselves okay so what are the
guidelines
what are we allowed to do because no one
was allowed to travel at this point
except for who key workers so we
circumvented airbnb we created our own
online booking
uh platforms for uh in reading and in
henley
so then we were able to then attract we
put marketing on their google ads
facebook ads all that other kind of
stuff to then attract
people who are still searching and we
focused on key workers so people in nhs
and all these other kind of people who
are still needing to work and then we
managed to get
long-term bookings so for say three to
six months bookings
not at the rate we would normally charge
however we still managed to make profit
on those months and i think it kind of
worked out a bit better because
we had the time saving we didn't have to
go in and do all the cleaning and all
that other kind of stuff turnovers etc
because
obviously coronavirus you're not allowed
to touch anything or whatever
so we had people in there for three to
six months at a time
and it saved us a lot of effort and time
even though we got paid less but then it
kind of
worked balanced out because i'd put in
less time and less effort which of
course
is money right but then but we didn't
have to put it that
put in as much so then it kind of worked
out to the same thing if that makes
sense
absolutely and i i think that anybody
can become financially free
make six figures go on to be a
millionaire it takes a special kind of
person to do that
someone that not only has the the
knowledge and the skills but also
someone's got that natural ability to do
exactly what you're talking about which
is to adapt and be fluid and it sounds
to me like what you did was
completely adapted the way that we teach
service accommodation
generally speaking and the way we have
been teaching it is don't compete
with airbnb and booking.com they're
spending
millions don't set google ads up and
stuff because don't make any sense
but if you just follow that like samuel
said don't
do but actually no no because now things
have changed
now i'm saying don't compete because
they're spending millions of pounds but
right now
they've got no bookings whatsoever so
actually the competition's gone
so you've actually got a little bit of
an advantage because
hotels have closed down right now and
everything's i know now they've opened
but at the time
were you stressed um to begin with
don't get me wrong the first when the
lockdown kind of happened i was in spain
as well and that's where everything went
nuts to begin with i was in spain
during the end of march and then that's
when they were like oh drones are coming
out
a thousand euro fines for being out and
i was in spain i was absolutely bricking
it
and that's when all the cancellations
were happening i was on holiday or
whatever and i'm getting all these
cancellations and i'm like oh crap
what am i gonna do what we're gonna do
and during that time obviously i was
uh stressed as hell but then
then i kind of accepted i didn't like
stress out i just
accepted that you know this is happening
this is happening
and i think it was to be honest i think
it's a wicked lesson actually because
for the first time i was when the 2008
recession happened i was
i don't know how old i was um 15 so i
wasn't affected i was in school
but now we're in another kind of
recession pandemic recession health
crisis or whatever so
it was kind of unique to then experience
that and to see
okay how am i gonna now this how is this
challenge
gonna affect me and how am i gonna grow
from this how am i gonna pivot
my you know strategy and what we're
gonna do so then i kind of accepted it
was gonna happen
and then made a plan and i think that's
what was
key to really surviving and maybe even
thriving a little bit during that
that period scaled the business and now
you've gone into management talk to me a
little bit about that
so what we're doing now is that we
because we've kind of built a good
solid foundation we have investors who
know what we kind of do
we now focus on the henley area
marlow and actually beckensfield so
where you live we're actually hoping to
get into this area
because we know that the dirt the the
competition is a lot lower
um and that the nightly rates can be
higher
so what we're aiming to do is actually
have source
deals bespoke for investors
really high quality ones we don't just
source any deal
we actually have a lot of relationships
with a few
let a few agencies one of the biggest
agencies in the world we actually have a
partnership with i mean well sorry in
the uk
we have a partnership with but i can't
mention their name but they actually
pass
us a lot of deals and they also pass us
um clients as well so people who are
coming in they're like from london for
example they're saying hey we need a
place for one two or three months
our budget is five thousand six thousand
pounds a month
then we actually get past those
inquiries from this agency
um so we're able now to we're able to
kind of cater for our investors to say
hey we have a really high quality deal
here and we also have high quality
clients who are
we're getting inquiries from so here's
the deal this is what we're doing
so we'll collect the fee four or five
thousand pounds fee for a rent to sa now
i know typically people charge anywhere
between one point five to three
but because of ours are really high
quality we go for
four to five maybe even up to six we
haven't done that yet but depending on
the deal
and the numbers but you don't you're not
doing that every day no no
you're like waiting for the really ideal
and it's sometimes the case of quality
over
quantity you're not you're not trying to
just sell as many deals as you can
to make as much money you're saying no i
mean this is for long term i want good
pro quality products i want to be
dealing with the right kind of investors
so you're charging a premium
but you're you're doing it less often
which is great yeah and i think
i think that's key as well because i
don't want to be known as the guy who
comes in with
all thousands and thousands of deals
every week and then you're just thinking
like how do you how can you even do that
i mean we only take on deals
that we would take on ourselves that are
super high quality
ideally fully furnished as well
all of that other kind of stuff so we're
just trying to look for high quality
perfect area and then ones that we know
and they're also
similar to ones that we already do uh so
we're not gonna go for like say
a six bedroom house where we don't we we
haven't done a six bedroom house before
so we're like okay we're not sure
what what how is this going to perform
but we're really good we found that you
know two-bedroom
flats and two-bedroom houses um we have
like in henley we have a muse
area and we actually have uh there's
three
two-bedroom houses there all detached as
well beautiful places right in the
center of henley
and all three of them hours as an on
rent to rent
um so we're just looking we know that
those work and we know that the kind of
demand that we're getting
and the kind of price that we're getting
so we know that what we can do there for
their investors
when you say you you'll only pass on a
house that you would take on yourself
i i've said that as well i used to be a
deal source so i saw a lot of deals and
had the same sort of philosophy
explain what you mean exactly by that
because some some people might say well
if you take it on yourself i only i only
pass on houses that i would take myself
well
why don't you well this is the thing
when you're starting out
that's what you would think when you
first start out don't get me wrong when
i first started out i was like oh i want
50 rent to rent i want to i want a
hundred of them
but now now i'm at a stage i'm like okay
you know what i know that rent rate's an
amazing strategy don't get me wrong but
then for me anyway it comes to a certain
point where
okay i've got enough units now but rent
to rent for me was in the be
all and end all it was just the the
starting point the foundations to
get me to the next strategy which is
ideally you know buying and then
flipping or
brr uh land developments etc that's
really the the
ultimate goal for me because that's
where you get the proper equity
you know and that capital growth which
is where we want to go
so and don't get me wrong i think
we we still are taking them on ourselves
because
i'm not just sourcing them with all of
these deals
we're still managing every property so
we still actually have an investment
into that property so we're selling it
on for say
four or five thousand pounds but then
we're still collecting a 15
management fee so you're invested in it
so we're invested in it which gives
which gives that
you know even that more confidence for
the investor that hey we're not just a
we're not going to sell you this and
flog it flog you off to
another management company we're
invested in it because
the higher rate that we can get for it
you know the higher revenue we can
generate we're going to make more
you're going to make it talk to me about
this because there's never a there's
never a black white
right wrong when you're talking to about
investments and property
it's always a multi-faceted um decision
to
to be made i generally tell people
not to buy rent-to-service accommodation
deals or
any kind of deals without knowing what
to do first themselves without having a
bit of experience without being
a qualified investor because there are i
know you you're
you know you've got integrity you've got
experience but there's a lot of sources
out there that just pass
any old crap and they're just trying to
get a quick fee
promise the world and and people get
burned that way the amount of people
i've
met that have been burned by buying
rent-to-service accommodation deals off
of
sources that make it look great on paper
but actually it's not
so i generally advise as a rule of thumb
don't pay someone money
for a property deal unless you
have the knowledge to actually find it
and do it yourself but actually
you're just thinking i want to leverage
my time i'll happily pay them but you've
got your eyes wide open
what do you think of that as somebody
who's had the experience of
being trained doing rent to rich
yourself now you're a saucer what's your
stance on that
so i think um it's always good to
not just go into it without this is what
we say to all of our investors as well
by the way you know just
do your own due diligence first on the
strategy first make sure that this is a
strategy that you
are well aware of and it's the same with
anything like you know if you're going
to have a
um you know a stock broker or whoever it
is
yes they can do it for you but ideally
you're not going to really invest into
forex or into some companies without at
least knowing
a little bit about it so we don't we
don't we don't want to work with anyone
who has
zero idea of what the investment is
because i'm not their teacher
i'm not here to teach them to say hey
investor i'm not going to explain
everything to you ideally i want them to
know that they want it
we only want to work with people who
know that they want to do it
i think you bang on there because the
problem is if someone's got no knowledge
they almost
are so trusting that they take away
responsibility for themselves so they'll
say
you're the expert you're the sorcerer
here's three grand four grand
make me rich make me and it's like
actually no you're doing the investment
it's your responsibility
so in my opinion you need to be educated
trained have your eyes wide open and
then if you choose to go into
i pay people all the time to give bring
me deals and people pay me to bring them
deals sometimes
but it's it's it's a wide open wide open
transaction
i'm not doing business with someone that
actually is is financially illiterate
that doesn't understand the investments
that doesn't understand property i'm
doing business with people that actually
know what they're doing
yeah that's key to be honest with you i
think that's
you just have to like you said you know
educate yourself on what it is that you
want to do
and if you need some help with it call
get some training get a source to do it
with you but
ultimately whatever you do whether it's
going on a mentorship
training investing or whatever
ultimately
it's your decision no one's forcing you
to do anything no one's got a gun to
your head to say
do this deal you know all this other
kind of stuff take this mentorship all
this other kind of stuff
it's your decision so you have to
educate yourself
and do it you've been in the game now
for a little while so you're quite
experienced
you've done you've done some of my
training do you think that sometimes
people want all of the reward with none
of the responsibility or the risks oh
definitely i mean it's just so
funny to think like how many people can
as soon as
when things are going right you know
this is happening so many people when
things are going right it's oh i've done
this myself
it's all me i'm the champion oh
something's gone wrong
it's your fault mate yeah you did it
it's your fault
then this straight away point the finger
and that's just such a bad mindset to
have because ultimately
your success 100 is down to you and your
failures 100
is down to you so you know you've got to
just learn from it and just take
responsibility be a man or be a woman
it's so true and all the training that i
do i now continue to attend training
programs i have mentors as you know
and the way i see it is they're giving
me tools
but i've got to actually implement that
they're giving me they're handing me a
screwdriver and a hammer but i can't
just like build the house i've
you can only build your own house of
success no one's gonna do it for you no
one's gonna
i think it's grant cardone that says no
one's gonna just come into your house
and make you rich i thought i didn't do
that one time though to somebody yeah
well if that house made them rich not
quite but um
yeah it is what do you think the most
important skill is in this business
oh um
i i actually talk about um
[Music]
i actually think sales is is a good
skill but
with with the word sales there's a lot
that encompasses it
so for example uh when people ask me
okay what did i do
um it was a kind of a variety of things
it was like mindset getting
make sure that your mind is like
undefeated it just can't be penetrated
by bs
by people who are going to bring you
down by family members by friends who
are just like maybe just maybe if
they're a bit
threatened that you might you know
flourish away from them if that makes
sense
um but then same mindset but i
communication i think is super super key
and to be able to build rapport with
someone
um i think the best thing i say to them
because there's so many people who are
like oh how did you do that how did you
get the agent to work with you and all
this other kind of stuff
it's all about relationship building but
then i say
i talk to everyone and i'm sure you can
feel the same i'm sure amelia feels the
same or however when i talk to people i
literally talk to everyone even on the
phone i've never met
talk to everyone out there my friend i
just picture them like you're my mate if
i talk to you like you're my friend
it kind of it comes across in your tone
of voice and all that other kind of
stuff and then it just you're more
relaxed and you're comfortable
as long as you and then of course if you
know what you're talking about it makes
it
a bit easier but i think you know
mindset communication
body language and all that other kind of
stuff i think it's for me
those are the skills that i think are
really important to then
marry up with whatever knowledge it is
property knowledge stocks knowledge
personal training or whatever
businesses you're gonna do i think those
are the kind of core skills to focus on
first and then you can translate that
into anything that you do that's so true
i mean
i see as there's hard skill soft skills
hard skills meaning the technicality
side of property investment whatever
you're doing
rent to rent whatever soft skills
would be sales would be a soft skill
just it's a skill that's that's
applicable to anything it's not a niche
technical skill
but i would agree i think sales is
probably and it's funny because i
interview people every week on when it's
wednesday
and i really believe that
to become to make two grand a month from
property you can be
a little bit rubbish at everything you
can be a dum-dum
you can be um you can have little drive
you've just made a few decisions taken
some action and you've made two grand a
month
great stuff good for you anyone can do
that in my opinion
becoming a millionaire or or even not a
millionaire but just
very successful having a business
employing people
really making things happen i think
you've got to be good at sales and i
believe it is a skill that you can
completely
learn but you gotta be good at sales
because
money money doesn't come from property
money comes from people if you sell a
house
the person that's paying you is the
person that's buying the house your
tenants your guests your agents
money comes from people and if you can't
communicate articulate and sell yourself
sell your product sell your service
to people you're not going to do much
business so
that being said give me some tips on
sales
tips on sales okay we're getting getting
an agent on side getting a landlord
wicked um so that's what it is right
sales yeah definitely so
um i think the best way to do it is i
focus first on communication so
what is communication first you know you
have verbal which is
me talking to you but then we also have
the non-verbal cues
so what is verbal verbal is just words
but little do people
a lot of people know is that only seven
percent
of communication is verbal only seven
percent that is what i say
the rest of the 93 is body language
tone of voice facial expressions and all
that other kind of stuff so
you have to think about like okay how
how can that how how can i actually
utilize
these skills to then to my benefit
whether it's in an interview a
relationship with a landlord or to an
agent and stuff i think
the key thing is it's a lot harder on
the phone but if you're in person i'll
i'll give you some tips for in person
let's say
the first thing that i say uh to to
people when i'm just telling them
about about body language is eye contact
i think
it's really key to have eye contact look
at you for example you know we've had
really good eye contact i think
throughout this whole interview
night now i'm weird about it now yeah
don't get it for dog don't get weird on
me man
so i say that to a lot of people and
it's a really good practice as well
because so many people
are on the street for example and we're
literally like we're walking on the
street by ourselves
and you know maybe there's a group of
people walking towards you a lot of
people
sometimes and it's just like in not
innate in us but we're just like brought
up
this way like so you're walking past a
group of people and for some weird
reason i don't know why we're just
brought up like this in the system but
like
people are just a bit like oh i'm a bit
timid here they take their phone out
on their phone as soon as they walk past
that group then they're off the phone
and then they walk or they completely
look away from those people
and it's really weird uh to think about
how uncomfortable you can get
when you're walking a past a group of
strangers so one thing i say to people
is practice this this this technique and
this is what i
first did when i learned about body
language uh
is basically look at the person uh when
you're introducing yourself to
an investor or a landlord whoever it is
a new friend
you look at them in the eyes and as
uncomfortable as it is you keep looking
at them until
they break eye contact with you first
and then you kind of establish yourself
as a bit of confidence
you have uh you what do you call it um
a bit of alpha there's a bit of alpha in
there but and that's a bit of dominance
in there it's all psychological it's all
subtle things like you would never know
about it
unless you you know about it right so
doing that first is super super key and
then
going in for a handshake as well is
really important
um as like in terms of when you do a
handshake there's a there's a few ways
to do it that there's if you do a
handshake with someone
and your wrist let's say let's say some
some people go for a handshake like this
palm up as soon as you do that it's uh
it's a submissive
handshake you're you're literally saying
oh you're dominant i'm submissive but
then if you go the other way around and
then
there's his palm up and then your wrist
this bit here is facing up
you're now dominant but then sometimes
it can be really really subtle like it
could be like that
and then you know sometimes when uh when
you're shaking someone's hand that
you could be trying to turn their hand
that way but they're trying to turn it
that way and you're like okay i know
that this person knows a bit about
communication
about uh body language and stuff like
that's interesting because i'm not sure
i totally agree with that
if i'm going if i'm having a business
meeting with someone and there's a dude
who kind of does this with his hand or
whatever
i'm thinking yeah man i'll let you do
that i'll submit no problem
just just just give me the money i get
you i'll get you you know
that's fair that's a fair point i'm not
gonna get into a battle with somebody
if someone's if someone's trying to be
if someone's an overpowering personality
and i might be accidentally overpowering
at times maybe i don't intend to be
but if someone's if someone's being
dominant or trying to be the alpha male
i let them be the alpha male you can
turn my hands yeah i'll be your little
[ __ ]
just give me the money let me win the
deal see if i get the deal that i want
then i'm i'm happy you can you can be
the alpha i'll let i'll tickle your ego
yeah and and i'll tell you you know
that's all good just give me yeah
definitely it's all situational don't
get me wrong i mean what i've just said
that don't do that in every freaking
situation i mean it's just a it's a good
starting point especially like for a
for a sales interview for us yeah yeah
that's where i thought it was great that
you said that was great
about being uh acting as someone's
friend because
i remember actually uh i'm going to
refer to
tanya who used to work it with my
company back in the day
and she used to work as as an estate
with an estate agency and she used to
sell me a lot of deals
and every time she'd phoned me up with a
deal i mean i just wanted to
buy from her because she'd ring me up
and i'm like why do i want to buy from
tanya
why do i want to buy a house from town
the houses that she was bringing to me
weren't great but
and i was thinking why do i want it and
i thought i know why it is it's because
when she
rings me she doesn't just say like um
she doesn't go
and hello is that mr leeds she doesn't
say that she goes
samuel how you doing you know
and i'll be like oh i'm well and then
she tell me about the houses that she's
got
and it got to the point where i actually
went to her office i said look the
houses you're bringing me aren't good
i want to buy from you you're amazing
let me tell you exactly what kind of
houses i want because i want you to find
them i want you to bring them to me she
ended up bringing me so many deals
i actually brought her into the company
she worked with me for maybe a couple
years or so
and i think that the reason i wanted to
do business with her the reason i wanted
to buy from it was because when she rang
me up
she would speak to me like she was just
a friend and that is not a scale that
you need to spend
you know months and months practicing
it's just like
treat people like your best mates i
really like that point
that's a great point talk to me about
the technicalities then
so service accommodation rent to rent
or buying to do service accommodation
which is something that a lot of your
clients do
how do you stack the figures how do you
stack the numbers and how do you know if
it's going to be a good deal so at the
moment we're doing
um we're actually doing super
conservative numbers now especially
since coronavirus and stuff but in terms
of the numbers i think
it's easy for me to do the numbers now
just because of the fact that we've been
operating for a little while
so i think um you know we just do the
numbers in terms of
um like the what's our normal nightly
rate that we used to get
prior to coronavirus we've knocked off
about 20 30 percent
off that uh and then we're just we're
just stacking the numbers uh in terms of
you know what's like what's your
expenses
um what's the what's all the utilities
the bills the rent
all of that other kind of stuff and the
in terms of um
occupancy as well so we do we we do 50
and when we're doing the deals out as
well we show all of the occupancy so
occupancy at 50 60 70 80 100 this is
what we're going to going to achieve
that we also
we always say um 70 occupancy
just to be safe we like to we like to
like almost
under promise and over deliver so we'll
say that you know we're going to make
you say
let's call it 500 pounds per month on
this surely it would
massively depend on the house and on the
area it does depend on the house so how
do you work that out how do you
if you've got if you're looking at a
property you're thinking i'm thinking of
buying this i'm thinking of renting this
what's the formula in terms of like
finding
if i'm finding a property yeah or or if
i bring a house to you now this house
okay cool all right if i say that this
house which probably i don't own i rent
this place
i pay seven and a half thousand pound a
month for this place
let's say my landlord says samuel
run it as a renter service accommodation
it's all good so i'll pay him the seven
half grand
how do i know i'm gonna be able to make
profit on this oh
obviously it it's it is tough at the end
of the day i mean you can do all of the
things online you can check
you could check the area on airbnb
booking.com all these other areas and
look
at properties which are similar yeah and
then see
what are their nightly rates and then
also you know clock their calendars
what are their you know are they booked
out are they not are they available
and that do you know what that's so
genius that you can do that i'm glad you
said that
on the fact that you can go on airbnb
you can look at com
like for like properties and then you
can look at their calendars and see how
book they are
if they're fully booked and you've got a
like for lighthouse you can see how much
they're charging
or if they're half booked and they're
charging a little
that i think that's a really genius
point and then obviously people are
using like air dna and all this other
stuff
but the only thing is what i have to say
is that
regardless of wherever you're looking at
at the end of the day it's all a risk
because it could it could work just
because you've done all of that research
and you know you think it's going to do
that
it doesn't mean that you're gonna make
it are always gonna achieve that i mean
you could end up losing money on it
don't get me wrong
but at the end of the day you just do as
much research as you can to
you know research your knowledge reduces
the risk but at the end of the day
you're
always gonna have risks i think you're
so right
zion i think when you're renting a
property as a single let you've got a
pretty damn good idea
of exactly how much rent you're going to
get because because it's just
one tenant one ever when you do service
accommodation you can estimate
but you need to remember it is an
estimate because until you do it
which is why i am such an advocate for
break clauses
yes talk to me about break clauses and
how do you use them so we use break
qualities
in usually for six we go for six months
break clause
uh so then if after six months you know
you're
you're in a contract and things are
going really well then you can be like
oh hey you know
brake clause is here but then the
landlord's happy you're paying them the
rent we're making the money so then you
know we don't need to exercise that but
then
break causes are super important
especially
when you are starting out and you
haven't done this before or you know
maybe it's your second or third one in a
new area or even if it is wherever it is
if it is in a new area
brake clauses you're going to need them
because you don't know what you don't
know you don't know how it's going to
perform you don't know if it's going to
be
you know a mega it's going to be a super
cash cow or is it going to
is it going to you know flop so if if
that happens
you need a break clause in there um but
then sometimes
as well i mean having a good
relationship with the landlord
that's also key as well because like
especially during coronavirus i know
some
some people who um you know they have
really good relationships with their
landlords and they said to them hey you
know what we're in a sticky situation
um what can we do here then some of them
excuse me some of them actually said
um that instead of you know not paying
at all and then okay you can pay us back
in arrears some of them actually said
hey you know what
we really like you this is a really
tough time uh we're actually gonna
charge you
half of the rent yeah and then you know
and and then so you pay for half of the
rent
uh to then get out of that situation if
you're still if you think that it's
going to work obviously with coronavirus
and stuff it was such a massive issue i
think with corona
it was an exceptional circumstance and
and and landlords
a lot of us have said that generally
speaking if you just said to a landlord
i'm struggling to rent this out because
i didn't do my due diligence enough can
i pay you half the rent they'd be like
no you know and for anyone that doesn't
quite know what brake laws is
it's just if you take on a rent to rent
agreement or any kind of agreement
for say three years that's great you
want it long term
but you don't want the risk if it won't
rent out do you have in your break
clauses
the landlord after three or six months
or ever on the break clubs is
can also take the property back or is it
just one way so we usually have it for
six months for us and 12 months for them
yeah yeah so then we have the the first
we have the first
uh refusal if that makes sense i think
what i say what what what what do i say
because i've had this
recently where a landlord said to me
it's not fair because
you know after because i usually have
three months because i think that
it depends on the property but three
months is often long enough you know
if you've got a lemon or if you've got a
property that ain't renting
usually you've been about three months
you kind of know so so what i
i had a conversation with london
recently where i said look after three
months um
you know if it's not working out i we
have a break clause which means i can
have about the keys and i don't usually
make a big song and dance about break
clauses he's in the contract
if he goes what's this i explain that
after three months if it's not working
you can just hand back the keys but
you've got on the contract that i
haven't got a break clause
and and i said listen here's the thing
i'm investing
a couple thousand pound on furniture i'm
giving you up front rent
i'm putting my money where my mouth is
i'm advertising the properties
the only reason i'll give you the keys
back
is if for me the deal is not what it
seems and i can't rent it out
for you mr landlord i'm offering to give
you this much guaranteed rent
i'm offering to look after the property
keep in good repair make sure the
tenants are reasonable don't trust it
that's my guarantee
if i break that contract at any time if
i stop paying your rent
the contract is void anyway so you can
take back the property so you've got no
talk about you're going to get your
money
you're going to get your house looked
after because that's in the contract and
i need to know i'm going to get my money
and that's why i need a three-month
break club so that's kind of like how i
position it what do you reckon
maybe that's perfect especially for
people who are
you know who are worried about that kind
of stuff that's that's such a perfect
example especially
such a good pushback as well for uh for
the landlord because
at the end of the day it is a business
so you have to you know
portray that to the landlord you know
this is a business
right so and we're not 100 sure if it's
going to work but we know for
you know we've done enough research to
think that you know to estimate we can
do
x and x and y z another thing you can do
as well
is you can say listen if i'm the one to
exercise the brake laws
if i'm the one that pulls out of this
deal then
any time that i've wasted inconvenience
i will owe you that
however if you pull out of the deal and
if
i'll give you a break clause no problem
i'll give you a three month break calls
but if after three months you pull out
you're reimbursing me in the furniture
you're reimbursing me the tenants and
you're paying me the fees that you would
have paid an agent you reimbursed me the
and that's got to be joined into the
contract so it's almost like um
but with any business agreement not only
do you need a contract
but you also need a win-win agreement
you know win-win agreement that's this
is that's just
super important i mean like for for one
of the things i wanted to mention
to you so with my myself my business
partner we actually do
rent to rent over in spain now yeah yeah
so
it's actually quite a cool one uh so
it's serviced accommodation
with a twist all right so my business
partner
he actually had experience um with
running yoga retreats
okay and he actually has a quite a large
clientele base
of yoga instructors who want to have who
they in turn have their clients
and they want to run yoga retreats and
it's quite a lucrative business
yoga is super lucrative i mean like it's
it's just growing massively in
popularity demand is just ever
increasing
so then i said to my business partner i
was like hey you know what
what do you think of this idea if we do
rent to rent but
over in spain for your clients because
he has
he has their own properties that they do
it with but they haven't they have a
they have a like a huge supply of
clients that
are like waiting for two years or three
years until they can do their retreat
so it's like okay hey so why don't we
actually think about doing rent to rent
over in spain on some villas for
these clients so we're actually doing
that now over in spain where we're
renting about you know 12 to 14 bedroom
villas
over in spain and then doing
weekly um weekly
rentals for the for the yoga instructors
where they will come in they'll pay
maybe
uh anywhere between five to six thousand
euros for a week
uh then obviously we have to pay some of
that to landlord expenses and what have
you but then they will have
say call it a 12 bedroom they'll have
their 12 clients who are paying them
1 000 euros each so then so everyone's
making the money the landlord's making
their money on their villa
we're making our money from from from
the yoga instructor then the yoga
instructors making their money from
from their clients and it's just a mad
amount like you said you know
how money comes from people and it's
just all coming in
everyone's just everyone's giving their
service and everyone's just making their
money
so that's something really cool that um
we're hoping to
uh package that up into for investors as
well there is a
is a lot more of a obviously capital
upfront is a lot more for for these kind
of deals but then
it's actually like they're they're not
rented throughout for the year we can
have a contract but it would be more
like a six to eight month contract
because that's the really the window of
the seasons that you can do it yeah so
that's the so that's what we're looking
at as well maybe
maybe eventually teaching that i'm not
sure but we want to be able to
um have that with investors to offer
investors
that kind of bespoke different kind of
because this strategy
rent to rent works worldwide i've got
students in america
in australia netherlands germany it
even i i don't know if it's true i had
someone that commented on youtube saying
that they were in china
making six figures via rent to rent off
the back of my online training and i'm
like
i need to get them on winners wednesday
but that sounds like yeah and i know
some people i know i've got some
groups of friends in dubai as well who
are really interested in doing that as
well and i said to them hey you know
why don't you go for it because dubai is
the the rent's actually still quite high
don't get me wrong but people are
spending money like anything
yeah so where are you going from here i
mean
you you've scaled the business you've
now doing management you're doing great
you hit your six-figure thing that's why
i wanted to get you back on the show
people often say to me you know how's
this person getting on now and how's
that person so
uh you know i don't like to keep getting
the same people on again and again but
soon as i've got to put them on a second
time
what's the plan now what's the plan of
the next six 12 months cool so
we've actually got a project in the
works now which is
um kind of it's a network it's called
elevate
property network and the whole idea
what we're doing with this is basically
we have we have a list of investors
ourselves right
what we want to do is we're going to
work with only reputable sources we
don't want to work with just anyone
we're going to
analyze these people's deals right and
we want to work with a sourcer
for say rent to rent all types of
sources for land development whatever it
is but we don't want to work with too
many but quality sources
in say every major city this is going to
take a long this is a long project this
will take a long time but what we're
going to do is
have sources in every major city and now
we're going to have
investors who are most likely hands off
you know maybe they don't really mind
where
where in the uk that they invest as long
as they can get a good roi
um or they could be investors in those
cities as well and they're also
management agents uh this is more
specific for rent to rent
nsa so the idea is we have a network of
sources
who might have some deals and stuff that
will come to us and say hey
we have say 10 blocks of flats in
reading do you have anyone interested
then we might connect them with a
an investor split those fees 50 50. and
now let's say that investor
in an ideal situation wants a hands-off
investment um
let's say it wasn't me for example
because i operate in reading but let's
say i didn't
for hypothetical sake um then what we
would do is then connect
that investor with a management company
who is replicable again someone who we
know who so a
good way to to know if they are good
enough is if they survived coronavirus
basically then if they survive
coronavirus then we know that hey you
know
you guys must be pretty good you know
you know what you're doing kind of thing
so then what we would do there is
either collect a fee and introduce us
fee from that investor because now that
investors got 10
units right then we say to the
management company hey we've got 10
units here for you
for you to manage it's going to cost you
say 1 000 pounds per unit
but that agreement's for three years and
you're going to get your fee so and so
forth or we can have another scenario
where we take maybe one percent
for the whole agreement uh out of that
revenue so we're kind of creating a
network of just
massive facilitation that's i love that
and i love how often when i ask people
kind of like what's next
they're like oh well um i'm making quite
good money and i really thought about it
you're like right here
we're doing it it sounds like uh code
sourcing on steroids
yeah pretty much i mean because the
thing is well and i know that so many
people want to do this they're like
you know with deal sourcing you you are
sometimes you know restricted to your
patch into your area
and then you you want to stick to where
you're comfortable you know i'm not
going to go all the way up to manchester
or scotland to start sourcing because i
don't know that area but if i know
someone who does
know the area and i can connect them
with an investor and then that investor
with a management company and i just
collect my fees all the way around
then hell we know we're all we're all
winning where everyone's getting a good
service and
the key is like i said before you know
we're going to qualify
each of these individuals qualify these
sources qualify these
management companies and and qualify of
course the investors as well
uh and that's where that's where we're
at now just hoping to grow that more and
more
and uh make tons and tons of money i
can't
i can't wait to see that happen and and
i think that the way your mind works is
thinking about how can i actually add
value how can i how can i
provide a service or or an operation
that helps other people make money and i
can't remember who it wasn't said that
help enough people get what they want
you get what you want so it sounds like
you're on the right track i'm excited
talk to me about the um talk about what
what you feel is because i know you
came from um some of my training you did
the crash course you've watched a lot of
the youtube videos
uh talk to me a little bit about the
importance of training and what you
what you feel about that i think so
training is super important because when
i started out
um i did every
majority of it was myself i did most of
it myself uh
obviously looked at youtube videos and
loads of other stuff your content was
absolutely amazing especially at being
free
so by doing it myself i still
managed to do it don't get me wrong but
all i can say is that it took me
hella long time yeah it took me so so
long
to and i had to you know i know and also
at that time when i was starting out and
i think everyone has this you know you
have a bit of fear in you you know
you're getting things wrong
oh i don't know if i can i'm not sure
about myself you have a bit self-doubt
and all this other kind of stuff
but then when you do have a trainer or a
mentor or you go on some sort of program
that literally just
says to you step by step this is what
you need
you don't need anything more you don't
need anything less
this is the package these are the tools
it literally
and you get those in place you get those
tools in place it just accelerates
your journey massively so for myself
when i
you know when i had a few mentors from
my own network who are in a position
that i want to be in and they told me
x you need to do x y and z instead of me
trying to figure it out myself
it literally it catapulted me like years
i would honestly say
years faster than it would have taken me
if i did it myself
you know what i think people can be so
small-minded when it comes to and it's
i i always ask people other people's
opinions because people sometimes think
oh because you run a training company
you would say that but
but i run a training company because i
believe that and i spend a lot of money
on training myself
but i think that when you try and cut
corners by saying i don't want to spend
that 500 pounds i don't want to spend
that thousand pounds for this training
course or for this
i want to save the money you're going to
end up spending 10 times that
on making mistakes and i know you've not
done
um a lot of our advanced training you've
done our crash course you've been a big
fan of watching a lot
you almost do describe the youtube
channel as like a mini encyclopedia when
it comes to property
um which is which is great and i and and
this i advocate that i'm like come to
the crash course and you're going to get
all the foundational knowledge
for sure but if you want a little bit
more support and a little bit more
mentoring and hand-holding
then we have we have options to do
further training and that's fine but but
but i think that people sometimes
try and save their pennies but then they
lose their pounds
yeah that's that's that's that's key as
well i mean like
there's so many people for everyone
who's watching this
don't try and get into not just this
business but any business
thinking you're not going to spend any
money because there's so many people out
there who want to do it without spending
a penny that's not the right mindset
ideally before starting any business you
want some sort of foundation you want a
few thousand quid in the bank ideally
maybe five grand or something then you
can actually set up your business
properly
you know get maybe some contracts get
your website set up all of these things
that
give you your online presence like your
website for example is like your cv
you're not going to get a job without a
cv first
you know so you need to have all these
things in place to then
you know further your business and all
that other kind of stuff so with
training
um it's just it's for me i think it's
important
if you don't if you need that
hand-holding experience then go for it
because ultimately you're going to save
time and what is time time is money
you know what i mean time is currency so
by being able to do things faster
yeah and the nonsense as well i mean the
thing that really just i just think
you guys just don't you talking about
when i see people saying you know you
don't need to pay for training because
it's all online for free i'm like
the amount of garbage online if you if
you type in online how to get a rent
service accommodation how to
i mean a lot of the property forums say
that rent to rent is a
people are so dumb so so you believe
what you read online
i mean there's a lot of big property
forms that just for honor venture events
don't work
so so you you cannot just get the
information online because there's so
much nonsense out there
i tell you one thing this is such this i
say this saying to so many people and i
think this is so true you know that
saying it's it's not
it's not monkey read monkey do
it's a monkey see monkey do you know so
you have to see it you can't just
read it and then do it you have to see
it and then do it how do
how do kids learn anything they imitate
their their parents if
their parents are out playing sports
their kids start playing sports
you know if they're reading books the
kids start reading books monkeys see
monkey do imagine if i'm stuck i don't
need to teach my kids anything about
life i don't need to raise them i don't
tram i'll just give them some books
you know they can have it for free no
you're going to spend time with them
you're going to teach them you're going
to speak to them so i love that that's
great
and honestly i think that you know
surrounding yourself with the right
people as well is so important i think
you've got a great support network
you've got great friends
um you've been a support to people as
well on
on some of some of our training you've
connected well
um because there's a lot of people out
there that will try and protect you from
becoming successful
yeah stay away from those protectors
they have good intentions give me some
red flag signs in people
the kind of friends where not say
they're bad people but some red flags
things they might say where you'd say
you know what if you want to be
successful probably limit your time with
those people
yeah i think there is to be like oh
people who question
what you're doing like oh are you sure
that you want to do that i was like oh
oh here's the best thing actually oh
like for example let's just take you for
example oh i sourced this video on
samuel leeds
he's done this he's that la la la la la
don't do that he's a scam artist
you know whatever chef said whatever
that kind of thing and it's like okay
well
those kind of people it's like do you
know what they it's you can feel it you
just
feel the energy from those kind of
people that they they
want something to go wrong so they can
have you back
they want you back with them like oh do
you stay with me i want you to stay on
my level no no don't go away
he's a scam artist what you're doing is
wrong get a job again
let's let's hang out let's go for drinks
all this other kind of stuff i think you
can just
feel that energy to be honest with you
and those are the flags there and and i
think you're so right about people that
try and have you back when you become if
you're from a family or
from a friendship group you're at school
with friends you leave and you suddenly
start becoming a little bit successful
or even showing signs that you want to
become successful they want to keep you
and they want and in their mind they
want to keep you close but but actually
what they do is they're keeping you down
it tastes something really interesting
when people come to the crash course
they say it's a weird experience because
everybody in the room wants you to win
yeah and it's it's normally that's not
the environment normally the environment
is everyone's competing everyone wants
you to fail
at the crash course there's hundreds of
people all wanting you to win what
was your experience with the crash
course talking about it mad energy just
mad energy
people were super excited and then it
was just more for
for me when i went there i remember it
was just more to like actually
see because i was a beginner then it was
more just to see like
is this actually real you know and then
you go there and you see a holy crap
there's so many people here there's
so many people who are already doing
deals sourcing deals you're getting all
the testimonies of people coming up
people who are absolutely killing it and
you're thinking i'm i'm not missing out
on this
you know i mean that's what i thought
and your belief levels go up high the
energy that you deliver
massive energy you know it's wicked you
hype everyone up
and getting people to believe in
themselves and that's that's super
important and here's the thing as well
when you when you talk about hyping
everyone up
see you see what what i don't want to do
is just my other people you could
like the way i hide people up the way i
get people jacked up
is by doing it live on stage like i'll
be like right someone give me an area
and i'll collect my phone out and do it
so i think
as you say when you've seen it it's like
i can't
not i can't unsee that i've just seen it
i can't unsee it and then it makes you
think
that's now my new normal how could i go
to work and work my ass off for 1500
pounds when i just saw
this guy and this happened in this deal
and people are doing that
all the time you know i think when you
see it
yeah definitely like i said my monkey
see monkey do
best advice as we wrap up for someone
watching this
maybe in your situation when you start
how long when we when did you come to
the crash course
i came um 2018
november okay so 18 months or so
coming up to two years coming up to two
years
so what what what advice would you give
to someone who's maybe starting out
watching watching some videos thinking
is this for me
is this even legit can i do this what's
your advice
my advice is just to actually
try it go and see what it's about
and try it because ultimately you're
never gonna know what you can do or what
you can become
without trying you have to try and if
you fail
that's completely fine because you have
to fail each failure
is a is a block to the to the next
success or to maybe to the next failure
but then each time
you're learning and it's all about
learning about yourself about whatever
strategy works for you it might be rent
to rent it might be brr
it might not even be property altogether
you might just think to yourself hey you
know
you know property wasn't for me but i
learned a lot and then so you know then
you can leave
yourself knowing that at least you tried
it's not you can't regret
why would you plus it's risk-free
especially going to the crash horse is
risk-free you know it's free
but go for it i would say give it a try
and it's so interesting to see some
people that have failed
in property but they've been to the
crash course or whatever but they've
actually used the skills the soft skills
the confidence the sales the ability to
talk to people to even crutch a deal
to know numbers and they've actually
helped them in their business in their
life
and they've not gone on in the typical
way like you have to do really great
things in property per se
but as as you said you've got nothing to
lose so i appreciate you coming down to
the house
beautiful place i look forward to seeing
you continue to win
and it's just really great to be you
know part of your story in a little
small way just to see you
winning to see you succeeding so massive
congrats and thank you for coming on the
show thank you very much my brother
welcome man i'm sure to see you your
properties pop up all over beckensfield
take over buckinghamshire all right god
bless you bro
luke's seeing him up luke say bye
bye see you man god bless